[Musica]
nodi che di opinione genio ne consegue
non è che bello sant'angelo
e ha demorso un po d'inglese
[Musica]
titanium
ciao ciao
[Applauso]
r
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ciao
[Musica]
calcio
aspetto
ciao
testo
certo
ciao
[Applauso]
[Musica]
da oggi
ma innanzitutto grazie per avermi dato
questa opportunità per superare un'altra
paura grande questa della vita vuoi
probabilmente e guardate questo filmato
di te questo è pazzo non ha paura di
niente ma non è proprio così per niente
della vita
due giorni fa quando mi hanno detto a
mare fra il ricorso ted mille persone
mia moglie mi ha guardato subito
maglietta nera per nascondere le due
pozzanghere che ciò qua
ma sono messo il deodorante non
preoccupatevi e quindi niente allora
voglio parlare oggi proprio di superare
le proprie paure perché noi tutti qui
abbiamo paura e ogni giorno
paura nel business nelle relazioni
essere genitori relazioni che c'hai con
persone con il mondo fuori abbiamo
sempre degli imprevisti
io dieci anni fa ha avuto l'imprevisto
la paura più grande della mia vita io
sono ho incominciato a fare calcolavo 12
anni e l'ho fatto a livelli molto alti
fino a 15 anni però pagato per viaggiare
il mondo non sono andata a scuola perché
non potevo solo sempre viaggiando era il
sogno e poi avuto un infortunio al polso
meno rotolo scafoide mi ha fermato per
sette otto mesi poi subito po di quello
avuto un infortunio alla schiena
sono andata a vivere fuori di casa
perché adesso a mio padre ma a quei
tempi avevo una relazione molto dura
molte pressioni che mi sentivo addosso
che mi mettevo io addosso di performare
sempre al top e quindi niente sono
andata a vivere da sola 15 anni ho fatto
il muratore ha fatto di giardiniere e
poi ho fatto l'istruttore e poi a dice
no poi ripreso comunque a fare kite ero
professionista però sembra non
guadagnavo quello che volevo guadagnare
avevo sempre comunque dei problemi non
ero felice quanto volevo essere li
metteva molta pressione addosso e ha 19
anni e ho avuto questo lo chiama il mio
angelo
siamo diventati cari amici markovski che
viene dal chicago e lui lavorava in
banca e il suo sogno era venire alle
hawaii e imparare a fare kite e io ho
segnato andare in kite siamo diventati
molti amici
lui aveva sui 40 anni molto successo lui
guadagnava molti soldi fa va bene e io
invece stavo bene
felice però avevo molte molte cose che
gli dicevo sempre
è sempre quello che non avevo quello che
avrei voluto avere ma lui ma questo ma
qua e là ma non va bene
li metto nicolò qua tu sai tante
potenziali se il talento se il coraggio
di vivere questo questo sogno che stai
dicendo però deve dc questi problemi che
ha avuto in bum bam sono tutte scuse che
poi sono giuste
ognuno di noi un percorso un tragitto
abbiamo degli imprevisti dei problemi
che abbiamo noi fisicamente
psicologicamente alimento nicolò watussi
responsabile della tua vita non c'è
nessun altro se tu ti crei quello che
vuoi vivere questi seminari questi libri
e mi ha dato questo libro chiamato
thinking lo switch di napoli quest altro
check in sul processo di jacques en
forme nato dei seminari non so se
conoscete anziani web e web procter
brian chase in one tutti seminari di
persone che ti insegnano come vivere la
vita dove puoi vivere una vita ricca di
gioia ricche di passioni e poi crearti
proprio siamo noi responsabili di
crearci la nostra vita
niente mi ha dato questo libro questi
seminari sei sette mesi prima che io
venivo in italia in sardegna sono venuti
in sardegna sono caduto in moto di nuovo
mi ha portato a far minare alla grafica
mi sono svegliato alle 4 del mattino con
questo dolore
se al posto di nuovo cavo sono a fare la
radiografia vedo lo specialista della
mano io sono stato operato quando avevo
15 anni velocemente aveva una vita che
mi sporgeva fuori l'osso che era
separato per sette anni io andavo con
questo dolorino quindi nella sfortuna
era una fortuna perché mi ha portato a
far controllare il polso e questa
sfortuna questa tragedia che che mi è
successo è stata quella che mi ha
portato veramente con i piedi per terra
mi ha fatto vedere dentro me stesso chi
sono io è veramente che cosa voglio fare
perché non ero non ero triste cioè una
una vita di lista ma non ero proprio
felice non stavo vivendo proprio quello
che volevo
avevo sempre tutta questa cosa perché
non andavano bene e quindi niente mi ha
portato a fare una radiografia visto tre
specialisti in due mesi del posto sono
nata a modena e ognuno in atto proprio
zero speranza mi ha detto a niccolò 1
l'ultimo che era quello il più bravo a
65 anni stavano in pensione detto nicolò
mi dispiace dirtelo ma il polso peggiore
che io mai visto nella mia carriera di
40 anni
dobbiamo l'unica cosa che ti devo dire
che possiamo fare dobbiamo togliere 3
ossa incluso lo scafoide chiuse metterti
le ossa insieme fondere le ossa insieme
quindi non potrei mai più muovere il
polso però poi stringere la mano quindi
almeno poi stringe la mano cosa stai
dicendo
cosa vuol dire cioè mi stai dicendo che
cosa sta dicendo no no non è così e io
appena mi è successo quello proprio
cominciato a leggere i libri a guardare
i seminari a capire cavolo ci possiamo
creare noi la vita che vogliamo e quindi
avuto questa intuizione in intuisce in
intuisce intuzione intuizione proprio
prima di vedere lui che metto nicolò
dovrei dire tu al dottore che cosa vuoi
avere quindi le uno specialista della
mano per il lavora solo sul polso ha
detto sono togliere 3 o ce la facciamo
così ho capito che lo scafo si non è
messo bene bene però dirvi che perché lo
scafo è l'unico posto in tutto il corpo
che prende il sangue solo da una parte e
quindi quando spezie si stacca a metà la
parte di sinistra o di destra dipendeva
dove vediamo non prende il sangue quindi
muore va in necrosi e quindi l'osso
savana non era già in sé inclusi era già
morto agli 8 il nostro si riattiverà
essere ha già rimpicciolito quindi
andava sempre in sub lussazione e quindi
gli ho detto wine perché loro volevano
togliere perché l'osso si muoveva troppo
dicevano a capri ha avuto troppe artrosi
troppi dolori e quindi ho detto perché
non invece che togliere il 3 ossa e
fondi milos insieme perché non mettiamo
un chiodo qui è un chiodo lì così che lo
ferma e poi tu non preoccuparti c ci
metto io la mia forza
e lui mi ha detto netto si è messa a
ridere se ti dico ok mi piace la sua
attitudine positiva ma la verità è
questa la scienza dice questa è ed è
così detto va bene un attimino cioè non
darmi perché poi mi ha detto che sarebbe
state due mesi prima che prima
dell'operazione quindi avuto due mesi
prima dell'operazione comunque detto
adesso vedremo quando torni vediamo cosa
fare in quei due mesi
leggendo i libri e ascoltano il
seminario incominciato a visualizzare
perché dice proprio questo visualizzato
faccia da verticale voglio fare gli
sport che io voglio essere un
professionista voglio viaggiare il mondo
mi sono fatto alla scala degli anni io a
30 anni
voglio diventare non solo un atleta uno
che vai parla al pubblico di dire la mia
storia di che perché io dopo gli ho
detto al dottore tutti dati che dopo sei
mesi un anno farò la verticale di nuovo
se messa a ridere e niente io sono
tornato 2007 guadagno è quello che
stiamo pensando di fare ricordo i due
chiodi non li mettiamo due chiodi
quello che posso non prendere il tendine
da qui e possiamo metterci una placca
cui una placca p quello che gli ho detto
io però invece dei dei chiodi i temini
ok va bene e allora niente
allora fatto quello stata l'operazione
giornali hawaii tre mesi che non posso
muovere il polso il perché ci mette tre
mesi
l'osso e niente in quei due mesi prima
dell'operazione c'è stata una cosa ma
perché l'opera staccato e torna dobbiamo
togliere invece in quei due mesi
l'osso sia di attaccato ed era era più
piccolo per quello che hanno preso la
decisione perché non hanno rifatto la
radiografia nanetto wow sel si è rimasto
un po in sesto all'osso devo dire
comunque volevano togliere hanno detto
non facciamo questo ateneo che è niente
io ho ripreso dopo sei mesi sette mesi
al settimo mese ma zero a casa con una
moglie stava già facciamole alimento
detto ma mi sento come se posso
allora sì ovviamente mi sono messa a
piangere dalla gioia è stata mi sono
visto la vita
che cosa è possibile e quindi voglio
lasciare con questo che non so chi
chi di voi che dai miracoli alza la mano
se credi che ci sono miracoli in questo
mondo ogni giorno perché ci sono
veramente miracoli ogni giorno in questo
mondo ed è quello che ho letto io non ci
credo sia mirato e anzi i miracoli
veramente ogni giorno ci sono cose che
la scienza non riesce a capire dice ma
com'è che questo è successo
scientificamente questo non può
succedere però invece ci sono ogni
giorno ci sono miracoli e quindi voglio
lasciare con questo che noi siamo
responsabili della nostra vita della
nostra gioia non il mondo di fuori non
l'economia non i nostri genitori ei
nostri amici
l'insegnante il dottore perchè c'è tanta
gente che i dottori dicono stai morendo
fra tre mesi cioè il cancro è invece
quella persona viva e fino agli 80 anni
c'è una forza della natura quindi noi
tutti possiamo vivere una vita ricca di
passione emozione dove piangiamo della
gioia invece che piangere dal dolore e
da quello che non possiamo fare
[Applauso]